Midsommar is a movie about a relationship
going up in flames - literally.
Writer-director Ari Aster has described it
as more of a breakup movie than a horror film,
one that he hopes will leave people, quote,
"feeling a little bit confused about how to
feel."
So: what happened?
As Aster has explained in many interviews,
Midsommar is about a relationship coming to
an end.
He told USA Today,
"The goal was ultimately to make a big, operatic
breakup movie that feels the way breakups
actually feel: catastrophic, like the world
is ending."
"It's an operatic breakup movie and a dark
contemporary fairy tale."
Like a lot of great horror movies, you're
not really supposed to take everything that
happens in Midsommar literally.
Whether all of this weird stuff is actually
happening isn't nearly as important as how
the characters react to it - particularly
Dani.
Altered states and hallucinations play a big
role in Midsommar's story, and subjectivity
is important to how the plot unfolds.
From Dani's perspective, the story plays out
as a series of increasingly-shocking revelations.
The movie looks a lot different from the perspective
of Pelle , the member of the Hårga commune.
Out of all of Christian's friends who come
to the Hårga festival, he's the only one
who knows what's going to happen.
“That’s why you look so guilty right now,
because you know.”
The audience also gets competing perspectives
of Dani and Christian's relationship.
The audience sees Dani going through an incredibly
traumatic time, needing the support of a loved
one more than ever.
But we also get a look at Christian's perspective,
seeing a guy who's falling out of love with
his girlfriend and tired of dealing with her
drama, whether any of it is her fault or not.
Complicating matters are Christian's friends,
most of whom clearly don't like Dani, and
are encouraging Christian to pull away.
"You've been wanting out of this stupid relationship
for like a year now."
Dani spends most of the movie as a passive
protagonist, mostly only reacting to events
as they happen.
She doesn't want to be a needy person, and
bends over backwards to take the blame for
her own clinginess, always going with the
flow in the hopes of salvaging her relationship.
So she ends up on a trip she didn't plan,
under the influence of hallucinogens she didn't
intend to take.
She gives and she gives, hoping all the while
that Christian, his friends, or the world
in general will just give her a break.
Nothing in her life feels in her grasp until
the end of the movie, when she's finally crowned
the May Queen, and given ultimate power over
the commune.
After spending the whole movie as a doormat
for Christian and his friends, she ends up,
symbolically at least, in control of their
fates.
In Midsommar, flowers represent family, with
an early clue to the symbolism being the floral
wallpaper in the bedroom of Dani's parents,
seen just before they die.
The metaphor can be extended to plants in
general - after the death of Dani’s family,
the houseplants in her apartment are all dead.
In the beginning of the movie, Dani's world
is dark and frigid, but things begin turning
around for her on the trip, in a place where
the sun rarely stops shining and flowers grow
in abundance.
Before Dani even consciously realizes it,
she's being introduced to a new family.
The first person to wish Dani a happy birthday
- the first birthday she's celebrating without
her family - is Pelle.
Dani truly begins being pulled into the cult
on the final day, when she joins in the drug-fueled
dance around the maypole.
For the competition, she's gifted a flowered
wreath.
After she wins and becomes the May Queen,
she's soon seen literally up to her neck in
flowers, all-but-smothered by the Hårgas'
adoration - her brothers and sisters, if she'll
have them.
It's a mutually-beneficial relationship.
The commune often needs outside members in
order to avoid inbreeding, and Dani needs
a new place to belong.
Her old family's lives were violently ended
- her new family has a violent start.
Midsommar's violent yet somehow serene ending
works on one level as classic, Wicker Man-style
folk horror, but it's also a strong metaphor
for a dissolving relationship.
Early on in the movie, Dani, a psychology
student, makes reference to the psychological
process of a breakup, seeing the signs of
her dissolving relationship in Christian's
distancing behavior.
In that sense, the whole bonkers final sequence
can be read as a ritualistic look at how a
relationship comes to an end.
As the movie begins its third act, both Dani
and Christian alienate and agitate their friends
with their relationship woes.
They become separated, experiencing different
parts of the festival on their own.
Christian goes into a trancelike state as
he cheats on Dani with Maja, the commune girl
who's shown signs of being smitten with him
ever since his group arrived.
Since we've seen him be drugged and hexed
to the point where his mind seems blank, there
is a strong sense that he is not doing this
voluntarily, urged on by sheer physical desire
rather than conscious thought.
It's the exact story we see in a hanging tapestry
earlier in the movie.
Meanwhile, Dani goes dancing on her own, unconcerned
about Christian's whereabouts.
With a little help from the Hårga, the long-suffering
couple is finally coming apart.
Dani starts the movie surrounded by people
who don't appreciate her grief, worried that
they'll abandon her.
The only people who show her kindness seem
to be Pelle and the Hårga.
After Dani bears witness to Christian and
Maja together in their ritualistic tryst,
she begins to emotionally break down.
As she does so, she's surrounded by followers
of the May Queen, all emphatically mimicking
her every noise and emotion.
Despite the obvious pain of the moment, this
sense of true connection and empathy is what
Dani has spent the movie looking for.
She screams, and everyone around her screams
back.
Unlike Christian or his friends, they share
her pain.
Ever since her family died, that's all she's
really wanted.
One of the more amusing aspects about Midsommar's
climax is the way the events parallel fellow
folk horror film The Wicker Man - as well
as that movie's certifiably insane, Nicolas
Cage-starring remake.
That movie inexplicably involved Cage's character
dressing up in a bear costume to disguise
himself before eventually just running around
punching people, a fact that's impossible
not to think about when Christian is rendered
paralyzed, and sewn into a bear carcass of
his own.
It's the same bear briefly shown caged up
on the commune grounds earlier in the movie,
not having a clear purpose until the movie's
bloody end.
Considering how much Aster has credited the
original Wicker Man with inspiring Midsommar,
it's not hard to read this detail of the bear
suit as an intentional nod to the remake,
adding a bit of dark absurdist humor to the
movie's fiery climax.
As Christian and the bodies of his friends
are being readied for ritual sacrifice, the
proceedings are watched over by a mysterious
figure, face invisible behind a thick veil.
The script for Midsommar names this character
as Víðarr, the god of vengeance.
But while this figure obviously plays into
some kind of Hårga ritual, he also serves
as a metaphor for Dani's emotional state.
The man refers to Christian, wrapped up in
the bear carcass, as a, quote, "mighty and
dreadful beast," whose death will purge the
Hårga society of its, quote, "most unholy
affects."
Even though she may not have ordered it deliberately,
this destructive ritual can be read as a very
personal action on the part of Dani, on whose
orders the commune is now effectively acting.
Whether she ordered it or not, this is an
act of vengeance on her behalf.
After four years of dating and a long, slow
withering of her romance with Christian, Dani
is finally asserting herself, and guiding
the relationship to a permanent end.
After spending the whole movie being passive,
this sequence represents her consciously letting
go, unleashing all of her pent-up frustrations
with Christian and his friends, to her relief,
and their doom.
Seeing her smile could come as a total shock.
It's cathartic, it's weird, and it doesn't
make a ton of literal sense.
But it does make sense emotionally, making
for a haunting final sequence that - as Aster's
said he intended - may leave viewers perplexed
about how they're supposed to feel.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.